we have to get to
i guess probably the biggest story of
the weekend
this awful shooting in buffalo there was
a guy who went in shot up a supermarket
in buffalo i believe 10 people
are killed
as always whenever there is a shooting
with a potential political or especially
racial motive everybody goes in
instantly and tries to
it tries to find out why the guy is
actually on the other team that's what
always happens right the left goes in
they try to make him on the right and
then the right goes in and tries to make
him on the left i guess actually the
first thing that happens is the media
will go in and decide whether or not to
cover the story and if the story
corresponds with their predetermined
political narrative then they will cover
it so if the story is about a white
racist killing black people they will
cover it they will make that a a huge
national news story
the president of the united states
as in this case will go and visit and
make a big media spectacle out of it if
the
story contradicts the narrative if it is
say a black racist killing white people
or black racist killing asian people
they will bury it they will not talk
about it that's what happened with the
waukesha killing that's what happened
with the new york city subway shooting
there were news stories for about 24
hours and then when the narrative did
not fit the media's preconceived
political agenda then they just buried
that news story the president didn't
have time to go to waukesha the
president didn't have time to go to new
york city but now he will okay
that is just what always is going to
happen i thought candace owens had the
best take on this she said don't forget
folks the media don't care about white
people the media don't care about black
people they the media only care about
power and so that's that's going to
affect all of the coverage here then the
next thing that happens is that everyone
tries to go in and make the guy on the
other side and so the left is obviously
doing that to the right right now and
the right to some degree is doing it
with the left too
i read the purported
manifesto of this killer i don't see any
reason to read his thesis on why he
committed this crime i don't see any
reason to say the guy's name i don't see
any reason to give him the air time and
fame that he is obviously seeking
but i i i will go in just to clarify
things in terms of who he is and
and what some of his motivations were
not what he was necessarily hoping to
achieve
uh
for his you know grand political thesis
but just what might have motivated him
because you're going to hear a lot of
misinformation
certainly from the left but you know
maybe some from the right too so he says
are you a christian
no i do not ask god for salvation by
faith nor do i confess my sins to him i
personally believe there is no afterlife
so if anyone tells you this is about
christianity or christian nationalism or
christian whatever that's not true he
said he says it's not true and he seems
sincere are you a fascist yes he says
he's a fascist are you white supremacist
yes are you an anti-semite yes
i wish all jews to hell he says this is
more evidence that he's not christian
because if you're a christian what you
want is for jews to
accept jesus and go to heaven and be in
heaven forever with everybody
not just jews but
everybody on earth you you were praying
for everyone's salvation this guy's
obviously not doing that he's wishing
someone to go to hell
are you a neo-nazi he says i support
neo-nazism are you a conservative no so
they're gonna say this guy's a
conservative he explicitly says i'm not
a conservative are you right-wing he
says depending on the definition sure
are you left-wing depending on the
definition sure and this is a point that
i i always try to make you always hear
the left invoking nazis and hitler and
they say the and they call everyone to
the right of hillary clinton a nazi and
and hitler and then sometimes you'll
hear people on the right come back and
say actually hitler was a leftist
actually nazism is a left-wing ideology
it's not a right-wing ideology and the
answer is
not everything breaks down on the left
or right
the answer is left and right which is a
political framework that comes out of
the french revolution and
describes the people who defended the
church and the monarchy on the right and
the people who defended the radicals and
the atheists on the left and the
revolutionaries on the left that doesn't
apply to every single political
situation hitler and the nazis had some
aspects of their political movement that
were right-wing that had some aspects of
the political movement that were
traditionalists and had there were
traditionalists themselves and had some
aspects of their political movement that
were left-wing the rampant atheism the
anti-christianity
the modernism the modern scientism all
those things were
the the statism that those things were
aspects of the left and so you you
really can't i know that's the least
satisfying answer of all but you
actually can't categorize
nazis or lots of political movements on
just the left or on just the right
he says are you a socialist uh depending
on the definition so he says in in a way
i actually am a socialist uh you're not
gonna hear that from the media what does
that mean it means you can't neatly
characterize this guy did you always
hold these views he says when i was 12 i
was deep into communist ideology from
age 15 to 18 i consistently moved
further to the right on the political
compass i fall in the mild moderate
authoritarian left category so that's
the category where you would lump stalin
or somebody in again this is going to
contradict the media narrative so you're
not going to hear about it and probably
the media are going to attack me for
even reading this but i think it's
important to read this
if you want to understand what the
motivations are
not because this guy is some grand
political thinker who should in any way
be emulated but rather because we know
that the media are going to lie about
this and so we want to be able to form
our own conclusions if we had a
trustworthy media we wouldn't have to do
that
and then this this might be the most
interesting aspect here tactically uh
this this looney tune says
won't your attack result in calls for
the removal of gun rights in the united
states it says yes that is the plan all
along you said you would fight for to
protect your rights and constitution
soon the time will come so he's saying
yes actually the reason that i'm i'm
using these guns and in the manifesto he
posts all sorts of information about the
guns is to get gun control because he
says that if there's gun control this
will really irritate the people who
defend the second amendment and this
could increase the chances of some kind
of uh war between the left and the right
or the races or whatever
uh
that's
really all i have to say about this
uh
there's nothing left to say that isn't
said obviously you know it's it's very
wrong to kill people it's very wrong to
embrace these insane ideologies
but the the rule of thumb
the rule of thumb that is really worth
looking at here
whether you find yourself being
radicalized to the far left or
radicalized to the far right or
radicalized to the far whatever if you
can't place it
there is no end that justifies an
immoral means we we actually were
talking about this
uh last week
or the week before that in in parts of
this guy's
ravings he said he asked will you regret
this and he says i probably will yeah i
don't you know i don't i don't bear any
ill will toward these people
individually i don't think they've done
anything wrong individually but my my
ideology that i've formed is such that
i'm just gonna suppress that moral
intuition and kill these people
don't do that people do this all the
time usually it doesn't have these sort
of tragic you know extreme consequences
but people do this sort of thing all the
time they believe that their ends their
political ends justify immoral means
they don't
they don't they don't there is no end
that justifies an immortal
almost all the time when you when you
commit an immoral action because you
think that there is some good end that
that will result in it doesn't actually
result in a good end but even if it
could then the immoral means would not
be justified you judge the action on the
action
itself
in a completely separate
sort of version of this a month or so
ago i was with ted cruz at yale and some
kid thought he was going to be funny and
he got up and he said
to end world hunger would you fellate
another man and he thought this was a
really funny question because
if we answered
uh no then we look heartless because we
don't want to end world hunger and if we
answered yes and we just said we would
fellate another man on stage and that
and the kid would have thought that was
funny but i actually didn't think this
was a complicated question
the question was would you commit an
immoral action for an ostensibly good
end
and the answer is no no don't that's
really simple stuff folks and we're
living in the age post machiavelli
we're living in the age where where we
judge everything by these abstract
calculations and utilitarianism and
maximizing the greatest good for the
greatest number even involves cracking a
few eggs to make an omelet
that's morally idiotic that's morally
bankrupt just
just do the right thing okay simple
simple enough
i'm so glad you like that clip now ring
that smash that like that click and make
sure is that i say that right i think i
did make sure that you get the
notifications for the michael knowles
show you can also go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review 10 star review if you
wouldn't mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you